So, my name is Iain Kerr.
I'm the CEO of Ocean Alliance.
And since 1971, Ocean Alliance has been developing benign research techniques.
These are tools that prove you don't have to kill a whale to learn about whales.
So, what we're trying to do is build a cheap drone that can be used by,...
...let's say, a seasick novice, to collect data from whales.
I'm Matt Rush.
I just graduated from Olin College.
We've been partnering with Ocean Alliance to develop a little air vehicle...
...that can be launched from the boat as soon as the whale is on the surface,...
...fly out to the whale, and then collect all of the blow which isn't water.
It's snot.
It's mucus and lung lining...
...and all sorts of good stuff that Ocean Alliance can get.
Stress hormones and toxins and DNA, all the good stuff that the scientists wanna see.
We live on planet ocean, not on planet Earth.
So, understanding what's going on in our oceans,...
...having these animals show us all the ups and downs, whether it be related to...
...acidification or potentially climate change or pollution,...
...they're a great bioindicator species, and we have a lot to learn from them.